alright well we got to move on alright
but before we go any further I do have
something I want to talk about and this
is pretty important recently ladies and
gentlemen we featured the heavy metal
band Slipknot on our programming
community this is pretty light they're
hardcore Slipknot is very hardcore and
they've become extremely popular very
successful heavy metal band if you've
never seen them before their
performances intense even frightening
take a look at them on our show
[Music]
yeah well unfortunately the last time
Slipknot was here there was a little
screw-up by sheer coincidence
I booked Slipknot on the same show as a
wacky comedy group called the slip nuts
yeah take a look at the performance by
slip nuts I slipped on some nuts that is
it the slip nuts act consists entirely
of them pouring nuts on the floor
slipping on them and singing that song
about slipping on nuts well afterwards
the slip nuts were really mad they were
really upset that they had to be on the
same show with Slipknot
they thought that that hurt them I felt
terrible about the whole situation so I
decided to use my incredible show
business powers to make it up to the
slip nuts all I had to do is make one
phone call and I got the slip nuts their
own gig at get this the Continental
Airlines Arena at the Meadowlands in New
Jersey
huge huge space a venue that seats over
10,000 people sadly and I swear I had no
idea how this happened I don't know what
happened there was a miscommunication
Slipknot the band was also booked to
play the Continental Arena on the same
night unbelievably the same night but
the slip nuts when they heard about it
they freaked out at first but they're
professionals and they were undaunted by
the assignment of opening for Slipknot
they went out to New Jersey they kick
some ass we sent a camera crew here's
what happened
here stop slip knit slip bean on nuts I
think I was the first one to slip on and
nuts and like I knew it was funny and it
was entertaining when I did it so I
think I can't remember if Brian or John
said like we should do that but all they
did was sort of point out the obvious
throws me I slipped on the nuts and I
almost fell down and Andy who was also a
student at the school we went to and we
didn't know him at the time you know
Brian and I are in the middle and Andy
is off sitting on a bench studying and
he just saw what happened and started
cracking up right had a 104 fever one
night and kind of I probably should have
gone to the hospital but um I am kind of
glad I didn't because the Slipknot's
just kind of appeared to me as a vision
I saw the sweaters saw the khakis I saw
these very shoes we had to special-order
these just to match my vision looking
for that look before the show we always
like to make sure our shoes are slippery
enough but not too slippery and so we
just kind of work them with the nut when
I get a good base I don't know if you
can see that nuts slipping so a lot of
people go through the whole life and
never slip on a nut and I feel sorry for
them they probably don't want to be felt
sorry for they probably don't know why I
feel sorry for him for that but I
some people never know what it feels
like this look here the slip not
slipping on us weird the slip not
slipping on thanks Panos open up for you
they're nuts all right lord grant us the
strength to slip on nuts grant us the
strength to clown around and then grant
us the strength to slip on nuts again
[Music]
great job thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of guys who take a break we come
back Robin Williams is here what seems
as though